[Music]
this week's 48 hours looks into the
mysterious disappearance of a colorado
mother suzanne morphew was last seen on
may 10 2020 mother's day if you can
believe it and police first thought
she'd been abducted on a bike ride and
then investigated her husband but as 48
hours correspondent peter van sant
reports some very bizarre clues have
emerged
the suzanne moorfie murder case
presented investigators with a puzzle
how to decipher a mountain of evidence
that included a chipmunk alibi a
tranquilizer gun and a pen right out of
a james bond film they find a spy pin it
looks something like this and they find
it in the master bedroom of the morphe
home
ashley franco has covered this case for
kktv
it looks like a normal pen it writes but
it can record
any type of audio as long as it hears
sound
the pen captured suzanne talking to a
secret lover her husband barry
apparently was unaware
investigators believe barry killed
suzanne because she had told barry she
was done with their marriage
the prosecution's case is that
barry
snapped at one point the day before
mother's day
prosecutors assume suzanne a mother of
two is dead her body has not been found
on that mother's day weekend in 2020
investigators noticed barry's cell phone
appeared to be pinging all around his
house
very morphy told investigators i was
running around the house looking for
chipmunks to shoot
a chipmunk alibi
prosecutors didn't buy it they had found
a clear plastic cap in the family dryer
that they say links barry to a
tranquilizer rifle even though suzanne's
dna was on the cap
not berries
animal care expert andrew caters showed
us a typical tranquilizer gun
this dart cap appears similar to the
plastic cap agents describe finding in
barry's home
could you now demonstrate for me sure
for a human being it could be lethal for
sure
prosecutors say that barry morphy an
experienced deer hunter had used a
tranquilizer gun to hunt and control
suzanne like he had hunted and
controlled animals
he was arrested for suzanne's murder and
pleaded not guilty
wow and ashley franco from our cbs
affiliate kktv joins us now you just saw
her in peter's report ashley you were
deeply involved in covering the story
there in the state of colorado it's a
really interesting case in particular
barry's so-called chipmunk alibi the
idea that he was running around his
house firing at chipmunks is there
evidence that he was an experienced
hunter
tony absolutely he actually admitted to
investigators that he loaded
tranquilizer darts with chemicals to
paralyze and shoot deer around their
property they live in a very wooded area
and he would do this because he would
put them to sleep with the tranquilizer
gun and then he would cut their antlers
off those antlers are very valuable to
hunters here but we'll see some of that
actually there's a picture that you'll
see from his garage with antlers just in
the corner of the garage basically
confirming all of this evidence
okay and then the spy pen did that
capture evidence of an affair
investigators say suzanne actually
originally bought the pen because she
thought barry was having an affair but
there was no evidence of that so
ultimately investigators actually found
something of suzanne having an affair
very interesting stuff ashley franco
you've been on the case for a long time
we appreciate it and you can watch the
suzanne morefu case nothing is what it
seems on 48 hours tomorrow night 109
central right here cbs